my mother was getting her hair done at
Europa in Ridgewood Queen shout out
Europa shout out sitting down getting
her hair done she gives me a quarter to
go over to the to the you know machine
where you would put a quarter in and
then turn the knob yeah and Eminem's
would come out one of those downstairs I
got an Eminem a peanut m m which is a
jumbo m i put it stuck it up my nose but
I was seven years old got the Eminem got
the peanut m m was so lodged in my nose
I had to call the fire department and a
firefighter who has to actually do real
emergencies have to now sit me down on
his lap and and get this like little
metal scraping tool and he and he got it
up in my nose and then he pulled it out
of my nose and because I was just maybe
just so nervous or whatever it popped
out onto my shirt where I was sitting
and I picked it up out of my shirt and
ate it
you should have tried to like crush them
we couldn't crush the choice we couldn't
and my mother is just a nervous person
we got nervous and we called 9-1-1 and
they were like they showed up and they
were like what's the emergency room and
we're like oh this kid's got an m m p a
peanut m m stuck up his nose oh my God